GOT PULLED FROM THE GAME ON
TUESDAY, TAKES ON THE V THE LEF
THEY HAVE THE CANUCKS.
>> Ale
GETS INSIDE POSITION, KINGS
TRYING TO ESTABLISH SOMETHING
SHOT UP HIGH ON QUICK, SHOULDERF
PICKED UP BY VANCOUVER, HORVAT
SKATES OVER THE RED LINE AND
DUMPS IT IN.
NOT MUCH OF A BOUNCE O O TURNED.
LIZOTTE QUINN HUGHES HAS
BEEN ON THE BAD SIDE.
HE KEEPS IT HERE, PRETTY GOOD
REVERSE BUT THEN THE KINGS DON'T
BACK  KOPITAR CUTS TO T THE
NET.
>> ALEX: LIZOTTE TO ROY DIDN'T
GET ALL THE SHOT BROKEN UP IN
AS THE RED LINE. HANDLING, SHOO
STICK AND  TARGET.
DICKINSON FOR HORVAT.
HORVAT TO THE P P LEAN-IN.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE STAYS PUCK.
>> Jim: JONATHAN HAS NOT BEEN A
FACTOR IN THIS GAME BECAUSE IT
CORNER, GLOVED BY
ONE-TIMER OFF A STICK.
ITBLOCK, KEEP
IT TO THE OUTSIDE, BY MILLER.
ARVIDSSON TURNED AWAY FROM THE
HIT.
KINGS MAKE A CHANGE.
SETTLES.
>> Jim: TRYING TO SEE KOPITAR
GET WIDE.
GOOD CHANGEUPAN SEE TO GO
BACK AND FORTHS AND AGILITY.
TANNER PEARSON, STRAIGHT AHEAD .
IAFALLO SHIELD FROM TANNER
PEARSON, PHILLIP DANAULT TAKES
MILLER AND THEY WILL GET A FRESH
SKATER O O
EKMAN-LARSSON, 1:10 LEF
FOR A TARGET.
IT'S MILLER WHO WILL BACK KEMPE
TIMES BEFORE HE HAS A LOT OF
TRICKS IN THE STICK
HANDLES, SHOOTS, AND SCORES. ST
OF THE PUCK.
SEE
BUT WATCH WITH JONATHAN QUICK.
NOT MUCH DECEPTION ON THAT ONE
BUT YOU C C ALL
THE WAY TO THE AND JONATHAN WAS
COMPOSED ON THISTICK, THE BIG
GLOVE TO TIE IT HERE.
>> Alex: HORVAT STOPS, SKATES .
>> Jim: GOALIES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH A GOAL.
STICKS BY THE THINK IN THE END,
YOU SEE A GOALTENDER BEAT THAT
LOW WITH THE SHOT BUT